a las vegas woman though has traveled
across the world to help the millions
who've escaped the war in ukraine and
she's helping families get back on their
feet in both poland and prague sasha
loftis joining us after speaking to that
woman and another woman who's trying to
get to the u.s
denise and brian these two women are
from opposite sides of the world one
from here in las vegas another from
ukraine they hope this story helps
others understand that those who've
escaped the war still need help
you cannot believe that it is happening
in
our time and in on our planet a month
after she was forced from her home in
ukraine victoria dichenko shares
everything she's been through we didn't
eat we didn't sleep we heard everything
all this bombardment she and her mom
left everything behind in keith
remembering what their home once was and
adjusting to life as refugees in krakow
poland we want to go somewhere else but
but what we can do they're among about 4
million who are now looking for a
permanent place to stay and las vegas
kathy healey has traveled there to
volunteer
everybody told me you need to go to
krakow to help and that's how the two
found each other victoria walked over to
my table
she was in the same restaurant with her
mother
and she said to me
can you help what victoria wants more
than anything else is to live and work
in the u.s
but she's hit some logistical roadblocks
so she and kathy hope someone out there
could have the right connections
everybody deserves a second chance so
this woman can forge her path
and start over
after a journey few could ever imagine
we don't know what and when will happen
this is limited in poland right now so
victoria has a friend in the u.s that's
paying for she and her mom to stay in a
hotel for the next four days but after
that they will once again be looking for
a place to stay